notre école est testée continuellement
nous le savons ces derniers mois nous le
savons les attentes à la laïcité ce sont
considérablement accrus avec notamment
le port de tenue religieuse comme les
abayas ou les camises qui ont fait leur
apparition et ce sont installés parfois
dans certains établissements la fermeté
de la réponse de l'école est mise à
l'épreuve par ses nouveaux phénomènes
face parfois au coup de boutois aux
attaques aux tentatives de
déstabilisation nous devons faire bloc
et nous allons faire bloc il y a
plusieurs mois déjà le Syndicat national
des personnels de direction de
l'éducation s'interroger les abayas les
kami c'est oui ou c'est non pour sa
première rentrée le plus jeune ministre
de l'éducation nationale sous la
Cinquième République à trancher ce sera
non invité dimanche soir sur TF1 il a
annoncé l’interdiction du port de la
Bahia une longue robe traditionnelle
couvrant tout le corps dans les
établissements scolaires le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a affirmé vouloir
donner des règles claires au chef
d'établissements scolaires qu'il doit
rencontrer dès cette semaine il faut
dire que les attentes à la laïcité ont
augmenté ces derniers mois selon une
note des services de l'État les attentes
à la laïcité ont augmenté de 120% entre
l'année scolaire 2021-2022 et 2022 2023
le port de signer est tenu qui
représente la majorité des attentes à
quant à lui augmenter de plus de 150 %
tout au long de la dernière année
scolaire nous allons faire bloc a-t-il
insisté ce matin lors de sa première
conférence de presse le trentenaire
s'est engagé à former aux enjeux de la
laïcité l'ensemble des 14000 personnels
de direction avant la fin de l'année et
plus globalement 300 000 personnels par
an jusqu'en 2025 forcément les
personnalités politiques n'ont pas
manqué de réagir à cette annonce le
communautarisme est une lèpre qui menace
la République je salue cette décision
qui nous donne raison à gauche la
députée et les filles clémentinottin a
quand elle juger la proposition
anticonstitutionnelle contraire aux
principes fondateurs de la laïcité et
symptomatique du rejet obsessionnel des
musulmans mais pour son baptême du feu
Gabriel Attal a également égrainé les
grands chantiers qui attendent son
ministère mes priorités sont claires
élevez le niveau faire respecter les
droits et les devoirs bâtir une école
qui émancipe et qui élève dimanche soir
le ministre avait également acté le
report attendu des épreuves de
spécialités du bac de mars à juin la
mesure arbitrée au plus haut niveau de
l'exécutif est un pas en direction du
monde enseignant vent debout contre le
calendrier du bac Blanquer accusé de
nourrir absentéisme et démotivation des
élèves au troisième trimestre ce matin
le ministre a également affirmé vouloir
et mettre le paquet sur les savoirs
fondamentaux à tous les niveaux en
maternelle aux primaires au collège et
au lycée car la première priorité pour
cette année est d'élever le niveau
a-t-il ajouté pour cela nous allons
poursuivre et achever le dédoublement
des classes en éducation prioritaire
notamment en grande section d'ici à la
rentrée 2024 enfin cette année 100% des
classes de grandes sections CP et CE1
seront plafonnés à 24 élèves et de
promettre les classes surchargées de ces
niveaux c'est terminé réponse dans une
semaine le 4 septembre lors de la
rentrée
[Musique]